AND LOOK A LOT OF US HAD OUR
ROUGH 2020. THE COWBOYS
ROUGHER THAN MOST IS THE NFL
GOES, BUT THE PANDEMIC REALLY
SCREWED THINGS UP FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS AND TRAGIC
WAYS FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN THEIR
FAMILIES. BUT WHAT HAPPENED
AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL WAS
PLENTY OF GUYS MADE THE
CONSCIENTIOUS DECISION NOT TO
PLAY LAST YEAR FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS. THE UNCERTAINTY,
THE LACK OF NATIONAL COLLEGE
FOOTBALL STANDARDS FOR THE
SAFETY OR LACK THEREOF THAT
WOULD PREVAIL IN.
IN THEIR WEIGHT ROOMS AND
THEIR LOCKER ROOMS ON THEIR
FIELDS. AND NOW WE SEE THE
AFTERMATH OF THAT. THE
PLAYERS WHO CHOSE NOT TO PLAY
LAST YEAR, WHO OPTED OUT OF
THE 2020 SEASON IN THE DRAFT
POOL WITH THE GUYS WHO DID
PLAY. LET'S LISTEN TO JERRY
JONES FROM YESTERDAY TALKING
ABOUT HOW HE AND THE COWBOYS
ARE VIEWING THOSE WHO MADE
THAT VERY DIFFICULT DECISION
IF YOU GUYS HAD NOT VERY MUCH
EXPOSURE, GUESS WHAT? HE MAY
NOT APPLIED LAST YEAR MAY
OKAY, HE DIDN'T BECAUSE HE
DECIDED TO OPT OUT SO YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN HIM SINCE THE
SIX PLAYS, HE RAN WHEN HE WAS
A SOPHOMORE.
LET'S HOPE WHAT ARE YOU
GETTING READY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION RIGHT THERE. HOW DO
YOU VIEW PLAYERS WHO DID NOT
PLAY LAST YEAR PROFESSIONALLY
FOR ALL THREE? HOW DO YOU
GRADE THEM? THEY'RE
COMPROMISED HOW DAD DIED
RATHER MUCH RATHER HAVE SEEN
THE REPS AND THE PLAYS THAT
THEY'VE GOT COACH HELP ME
HERE. HOW MANY PLAYS IN A
NORMAL SITUATION? WOULD A
LISTS, A DEFENSIVE TACKLE BY
PLAYING LAST YEAR'S OPPOSED
NOT PLAY IN LAST YEAR IF
IS A GAME, 10 GAME SIX GO
SEVEN HUNDRED PLACE, EVEN ON
PLUS PLACE, AND PLUS.
USUALLY THOSE PLAYERS IF
THEY'RE THE TYPE PLAYER YOU
WANT, OR OR BETTER
FROM THEIR JUNIOR TO THEIR
SENIOR YEAR, FAIR FAIR TO
SECOND. WELL, I'M SALUTE WHAT
YOU LOOK FOR AND SO THE POINT
IS IT'S AS MUCH INFORMATION
THEY DIDN'T PLAY LAST YEAR.
LOOK.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY ON PFT P.M. AND I
GOT MYSELF A LITTLE CRANKED
UP ABOUT. I'M GOING TO GET
MYSELF CRANKED UP ABOUT IT
AGAIN TODAY. KEVIN COLE BEAT
THE STEELERS GM EXPLAINED IN
A VERY CALM DISPASSIONATE
VOICE EARLIER THIS WEEK. THAT
IF ALL THINGS ARE EQUAL
BETWEEN TWO CANDIDATES,
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE THE GUY
WHO PLAYED LAST YEAR OVER THE
GUY WHO DIDN'T PLAY LAST
YEAR EVEN THOUGH THEY FULLY
RESPECT THE DECISION OF THOSE
PLAYERS WHO WHO DECIDED NOT
TO PLAY IN 2020 DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC.
I FEEL LIKE AND AND YOU
COULD THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES. CHRIS, THAT WOULD BE
GOOD TOPIC FOR THE DEBATE
CLUB IN HIGH SCHOOL BECAUSE
YOU COULD MAKE PERSUASIVE
ARGUMENTS ON EITHER SIDE OF
GOOD, THAT A GUY PLAYED LAST
YEAR. IS IT BAD THAT HE
PLAYED LAST YEAR? IS IT GOOD
FOR A RUNNING BACK OR OUR
DEFENSIVE TACKLE? IS IT GOOD
THAT HE'S COMING TO THE NFL
WITH MORE TREAD ON THE TIRES?
THAT COULD BE VIEWED? AS A
POSITIVE? IF WHAT WE SAW FROM
HIM IN 2019 WAS PRETTY DAMN
GOOD AND WE DIDN'T SEE
ANYTHING LAST YEAR. HE'S THE
GUY. YEAH, MAYBE HE NEEDS TO
BE IN A LITTLE BIT BETTER
SHAPE, BUT THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE GET GUYS IN SHAPE, BUT
WE'VE SEEN WHAT HE CAN DO.
YEAH. AND AND AND BEEN MAYBE
HE'LL BE EVEN BETTER THAN HE
WAS IN 2019. WE
LIKE WHAT HE DID IN 2019,
I'LL BE EVEN BETTER, MAYBE
I JUST KEEP COMING BACK TO
THE FACT THAT FOOTBALL AT
EVERY LEVEL, NOT JUST THE NFL
BUT AT EVERY LEVEL IT WON'T
ROBOTS. THEY WANT GUYS WHO
ARE GOING TO DO, WHAT THEY'RE
TOLD TO DO. THEY WANT GUYS
WHO AREN'T GOING TO STAND UP
AND PUSH BACK AGAINST THE
MOMENTUM, THAT SHOVES THEM
TOWARD THE FIELD AND ANYONE
WHO EXERCISES THAT
INDEPENDENT THINKING THAT
ORIGINAL THOUGHT THAT
MOVEMENT THAT PUSHES AGAINST
WHAT COACH AND TEAM WOULD
WANT HIM TO DO THOSE GUYS.
RED FLAG BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT SOMEONE LIKE THAT.
KEEPING US FROM DOING WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO ON OUR
FOOTBALL FIELD. I FEEL LIKE
THAT IS THE MESSAGE THAT IS
SUBTLY OR NOT COMING THROUGH,
WHAT JERRY JONES IS SAYING.
WELL, I DON'T LIKE TOTALLY
DISSING, I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH THAT. I THINK THERE'S
SOME OF THAT THEY'RE, YOU
KNOW. BUT HEY, I MEAN, MIKE,
YOU KNOW, PUT YOURSELF IN
THEIR SHOES, IT'S THE
BUSINESS OF FOOTBALL. I MEAN,
YEAH. THEY LIKE TO SEE PEOPLE
WHO PLAY FOOTBALL TO, YOU
KNOW, ACQUIRE MORE.
ATION, SEE WHERE THE GUY HAS
GONE AS A FOOTBALL PLAYER. SO
I UNDERSTAND IT, I MEAN IF
IT'S APPLES TO APPLES. YEAH,
I THINK IF I'M IN THEIR SHOES
TO PLAYING GM AND YOU'RE
GOING, WAIT, OKAY. I GOT TO,
LET'S JUST SAY, YOU KNOW, FOR
LACK OF A BETTER NUMBER. I
GOT A 7.0 GRADE AND A 7.0
GRADE FOR TWO PLAYERS THAT
ARE GREAT. ALL RIGHT, WELL,
THIS ONE PLAYED LAST YEAR.
ONE DIDN'T. AND YEAH, I'M
GONNA TAKE THAT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT IF HE'S RUNNING BACK?
IT'S BETTER THAN HE DIDN'T
PLAY LAST YEAR. OKAY, GOT
MORE REPS IN HIM AT THE NFL
LEVEL MET. MAYBE THAT COULD
BE A RARE CASE, YOU'RE RIGHT,
CAN BE, BUT I COULD ALSO SAY,
YOU KNOW, IT WAS ONE LESS
YEAR ON HIM GETTING BETTER AT
RUNNING ROUTES OR LEARNING,
HOW TO PICK UP A BLITZER OR
DOING OTHER THINGS LIKE THAT.
THAT AGAIN, THESE ARE YOUNG
KIDS WHO ARE STILL LEARNING
THE SPORT. SO YOU'VE STOPPED
THAT LEARNING CURVE A LITTLE
BIT AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE
IT'S JUST SCARES TEAMS, YOU
KNOW, COACHES AND GM'S AND
OWNERS. THEY'RE VERY
CONSERVATIVE THAT WAY, RIGHT?
SO
THEY WANT ALL THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE, IT SCARES THEM TO
A DEGREE, IT SCARES THEM WHEN
IT'S APPLES TO APPLES. AND
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO BE
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS DROP,
AS WE GET TOWARDS THE END OF
THE FIRST ROUND, YOU KNOW,
FIRST ROUNDS ABOUT ELITE
PLAYERS, SOME OF THESE TEAMS
ARE GOING TO HAVE NO CHOICE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE GUYS,
YOU'RE GOING TO GO. DO YOU
WANT A GUY WHO'S SUPER
TALENTED AND DIDN'T PLAY OR A
GUY THAT'S NOT THAT TALENTED
AND DID PLAY? AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR THEN THE
FOR TALENTED AND ALL THAT
INSIDE OUT. BUT BUT I
UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW, AIRING
OR I GUESS AIRING AIRING
AIRING ON THE GUY THAT THAT
PLAYED LAST YEAR THAN THE GUY
THAT DIDN'T THEY DIDN'T
HESITATE TO TAKE JAYLON SMITH
WITH A COMPLETELY WRECKED ME.
YOU KNOW, IT'S RISKY, RIGHT?
SAT OUT A WHOLE YEAR. I AND
THERE WERE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER HE COULD EVER PLAY
BUT THEY AND SEE THERE WILL
BE A POINT WHERE ANDY GREGORY
PLAYER BECOMES VALUE WHEN YOU
SLIDE IT AROUND TOO. AND
MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS THERE,
MEANING THEY'RE GOING TO BE
DRAFTED, THEY'RE JUST GOING
TO BE DRAFTED, LOWER THAN
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN. BUT YOU
KNOW, WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME
TEAMS. YOU GET SOME PRETTY
DAMN GOOD PLAYERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO UNDERSTAND.
IT IS A CASE-BY-CASE
DETERMINATION. BUT I STILL
THINK THIS THIS PRESUMPTION
THAT IT'S A BAD THING IF YOU
DIDN'T PLAY LAST YEAR. YEAH.
WE ALL STAND. WHY YOU DIDN'T
PLAY AND WE RESPECT YOUR
DECISION BUT NOW WE'RE GOING
AND I CAN BOIL IT DOWN LIKE
THIS WITH
RATE EXPLANATION FROM NICK
SABAN EARLIER IN THE WEEK AND
I WROTE SOMETHING ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY AND IT HITS THE
NAIL ON THE HEAD AND IT'S A
GREAT MESSAGE FOR ANYONE,
YOU PLAY FOOTBALL, ANY OTHER
SPORT OR NO SPORTS AT ALL,
YOU ARE GOING TO BE EVALUATED
AT SOME POINT FOR EMPLOYMENT
FOR ADMISSION TO COLLEGE
PROGRAM, POSTGRADUATE
WHATEVER. AND THE TWO MOST
IMPORTANT WORDS WHEN PEOPLE
ARE MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT
YOU ARE AND AND BUT YEAH, THE
QUESTION,
QUESTION IS AND THINK ABOUT
IT, THINK ABOUT IT IF YOU'RE
ASKING A GM OR A COACH OR AN
OWNER RIGHT NOW, IF THE
OPT-OUT IS PART OF THE STORY,
THAT IS BEING TOLD ON A
PLAYER, IT'S NOT AND HE OPTED
OUT, IT'S BUT HE OPTED OUT
THE NEGATIVE CONNOTATION. IT
IS RIGHT? NO ONE'S GOING TO
SAY AND ANDY CHOSE TO TAKE
CARE OF HIS FAMILY AND HE
REALIZED THAT THE SCIENCE WAS
UNCERTAIN AND THERE WAS SOME
VAGUE EVIDENCE OF PEOPLE
HAVING HEART DAMAGE AS A
IT'S HIGHLY CONDITION HAVING
HEART DISEASE AS A RESULT OF
IT. SO IT'S NOT A, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S AN AND BUT I FEEL LIKE
IT'S BEING COUCHED AS A BUT
NOT AS AN END AND THAT MAYBE
TELLS US EVERYTHING WE NEED
TO KNOW ABOUT HOW THESE TEAMS
HAVE YOU GUYS, WHO OPTED OUT
WELL YEAH I MEAN YES AND
LISTEN II UNDERSTAND IT TO A
DEGREE AGAIN IT'S THE
BUSINESS OF FOOTBALL AND YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE LOOKING TO
ACQUIRE GUYS THAT ARE GOOD AT
THAT BUSINESS WHICH IS
PLAYING FOOTBALL AND YOU'RE
MAKING BIG INVESTMENTS INTO
THESE PYRE.
OURS. SO WITH THAT, HEY,
THEY DO WANT, YOU KNOW, AND
AGAIN YEAH, THEY WANT A GUY
THAT DID PLAY THAT THEY FEEL
IS COMFORTABLE LIKE MAN. HE
WANTS TO PLAY FOOTBALL AT ALL
COSTS. YOU KNOW. I HOPE
THEY'RE NOT HOLDING IT
AGAINST, YOU KNOW, THESE
GUYS TO A CERTAIN DEGREE. BUT
YEAH, I THINK WHEN IT'S LIKE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO FAVOR
THE GUY THAT LIKE, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE GOING TO FAVOR THE
GUY THAT LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE JOKED ABOUT OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS THE MIKE
TOMLIN QUOTE YOU KNOW I WANT
VOLUNTEERS RIGHT? YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT HOSTAGES. I MEAN
EVERYBODY IS LOOKING FOR THAT
RELATION OF THIS NFL DRAFT.
BUT YOU KNOW, AT THE SAME
TIME TO, YOU KNOW, JERRY
SAID SOMETHING INTERESTING
THERE AS WELL WHERE HE'S LIKE,
YOU KNOW, HEY MORE TIMES
THAN NOT TO A GUY THAT YOU
LOOK AT AS A JUNIOR, RIGHT?
AND HE'S A GOOD FOOTBALL
PLAYER. I MEAN, ALMOST 98,
99 TIMES OUT OF A HUNDRED,
THE GUY GETS BETTER. THE NEXT
YEAR, HE'S GETTING BIGGER.
HE'S GROWING AS A MAN, HE'S
MORE MATURE. MENTALLY. I MEAN
USUALLY, OH WIGS, IS IT GOES
IN THAT DIRECTION? UNLESS
L'VE THERE. SOMETHING LIKE
THAT TOO. SO THAT'S WHERE
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING
TO SEE. YOU KNOW, WHO
BALANCES THAT WHOLE HIGH-WIRE
ACT THERE WITH THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE FASCINATING. FOR
THURSDAY NIGHT, I THINK THE
MORE ACCURATE EXPLANATION AND
WE WANT VOLUNTEERS, WE WANT
VOLUNTEERS, WE WANT GUYS WHO
HAVE NO REGARD WHATSOEVER FOR
THEIR OWN PHYSICAL HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING AND WHO WILL PLAY
THAT WAY ON THE FOOTBALL
FIELD. BECAUSE WHEN THEY GET
INJURED AND THEY WILL, WILL
SCRAPE THEM UP. AND WE'LL
WE KNOW THAT WHEN HE'S OUT
THERE HE IS, PLAYING WITH THE
KIND OF RECKLESS ABANDON THAT
WILL ALLOW HIM TO GET THE
MOST OUT OF HIS SKILLS. AND
WHAT BETTER WAY TO PROVE THAT
HE HAS NO REGARD FOR HIS
HEALTH AND SAFETY THEN TO
PLAY COLLEGE FOOTBALL DURING
A GLOBAL PANDEMIC. AT A TIME
OF HIGH UNCERTAINTY, THE ONLY
CERTAINTY FOR HIM WAS HE
LOVES HIM SOME FOOTBALL, AND
HE'S GOING TO GO PLAY AND I
REALLY DO THINK THAT IS
IMPLICIT IN ALL THIS, THE
COMBINATION OF IT SHOWS HOW
MUCH YOU TRULY LOVE FOOTBALL
AND IT SHOWS THAT YOU ARE
WILLING
WILLING TO FALL INTO LINE
WITH WHAT THE COACH THE
ORGANIZATION WANTS YOU TO DO
AT ALL TIMES. AND I DO THINK
IT GETS VIEWED AS A NEGATIVE
EVEN THOUGH IT SHOULDN'T
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
A HIGHLY TALENTED INDIVIDUAL
WHO WILL DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT, WHENEVER THEY WANT,
HOWEVER, THEY WANT. AND THEY
NEVER HAVE TO PULL THE RIP
CORD ON THE LAWN MOWER. HE'S
READY TO GO AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT, NO MATTER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND I THINK
THAT EVEN THOUGH IT SHOULDN'T
MISS TEST FOR SOME OF THESE
TEAMS ON HOW MUCH A GUY'S
FOOTBALL. AND I HATE TO EVEN
SAY IT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
WRONG, IT IS WRONG, BUT I
THINK THAT'S HOW THEY'RE
LOOKING AT IT. I MEAN I MEAN
YOU'RE RIGHT. THEY ARE THE
BIGGEST THING THOUGH. IT'S
GOING TO AFFECT THE MIDDLE
CLASS OF THE DRAFT AND THOSE
GUYS MORE THAN ANYTHING. YOU
AGAIN? HEY JC HORN PLAYED
WHAT, WHAT WAS IT, PETE A FEW
GAMES THIS YEAR AND THEN
OPTED OUT. OH GUESS WHAT?
MIKE, HE'S REALLY TALENTED.
NOBODY CARES AND YOU KNOW,
THAT'S NOT A CONVERSATION FOR
HIM, RIGHT? SO THE SUPER
TALENTED ONES.
KIND OF JUST GETS LIKE SWEPT
UNDER THE RUG, LIKE WELL
DOESN'T MATTER LIKE, HE'S
AWESOME. ALL RIGHT, YOU KNOW,
AND AND THAT THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE MORE ABOUT THE
SPLITTING, THE ATOMS IN THE
THIRD ROUND. AND THAT'S
WHERE IT'S GOING TO AFFECT
THOSE PLAYERS WHERE IT'S LIKE,
OH WE GOT TWO WIDE RECEIVERS,
ONE PLAYED ONE OPTED OUT,
LET'S GO WITH THE ONE THAT
PLAYED AND DID THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT TO AGAIN, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S GOING TO BE,
HE'S PLAYED MORE FOOTBALL,
HE'S HAD MORE REPS. WE SAW HIM
IN PROVE ON THE THING, HE WAS
AT THE YEAR.
FOR WE HAVE VISUAL EVIDENCE
THAT THE GUY WORKED AND GOT
BETTER AT IT, YOU KNOW, SO
THERE IS SOME LOGIC OF COURSE
TO THE WAY THEY'RE THINKING.
YEAH, I THINK THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A, YOU KNOW,
WHAT DO I WANT TO SAY A
CAVEMAN ATTITUDE? A LITTLE
BIT TO THE LIKE, OH, HE
DIDN'T PLAY. AND NOW I'M NOT
GOING TO TAKE THEM BECAUSE
HE DOESN'T LOVE FOOTBALL.
YEAH, OF COURSE. THERE'S THAT
PART IN THE NFL WITH ALL
COACHES AND TEAMS, BUT I
THINK MORE OF THIS IS ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, THE GATHERING THE
INFORMATION MORE THAN
ANYTHING. AND
I THINK THERE'S A WAY
WAY TO SPIN IT. IF YOU WANT
TO INTO A POSITIVE, I THINK
IT'S MORE OF A BUTT THAN AN.
WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE
SCOUTING REPORT AND BRING UP
THE TOPIC OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE GAUCHOS TO PLAY LAST YEAR.
I ITTH I'K S THJUATST  'HES